i didn't trust teachers
i didn't trust politicians i didn't
trust people on the evening news
[Music]
i trusted music the language of
my life is written in rock and roll
and punk rock and hip-hop
i'd like to teach a class that makes
your guitar playing
meaningful to you i'll show you ideas
in chords and solos i'm gonna go through
my entire
arsenal of guitars amps and effects
pedals
you practice technique to get your
fingers to go where you want them to go
you practice theory to understand where
they can go
and why rock and roll is a visceral
experience
and a connection with the audience that
should be exciting at its core
[Music]
i was the only black kid in all white
town and the only heavy metal musician
at harvard university in the world that
can be
cruel and is sometimes racist and is
grossly unfair
all of a sudden
[Music]
with this thing on i'm invincible
in this class you will be able to write
a song
and play a guitar solo then we rock even
if you've never
touched a guitar before
and for the advanced player the sky's
the limit if you want to play
exactly like me you're going to figure
that out in this master class
if you want to play guitar exactly like
you
i'll reveal how you can create
a lifetime of awesome rocket
[Music]
i'm tom morello and this is my master
[Music]
class
you